if you please
i am dorothy if there's any film that's
withstood the test of time and deserves
the imax treatment it's wizard of oz
this film is so unique the legacy its
history
we're really proud to have had an
opportunity to be a part of it
i started working with wizard of oz back
about
22 years ago and it's been great to see
it
in different incantations wizard's the
oldest film that's ever been converted
to 3d
and it's a real testament to the
craftsman who worked on it and the
photography at the time the three strip
technicolor
that it can still hold its own
technologically
the original film elements had to be
scanned so that they were sharp
and then the dirt had to be cleaned up
the scratches all the imperfections that
had built up over the years from the
handling of these elements
had to be taken out digitally then prime
focus did their
3d work so we're dealing with a 3d
conversion the layering of the shot is
definitely key as far as
putting things in proper 3d space we
have a lot of layering that they did
when they originally shot in 1939
so for us we would have to go through
and isolate all those different objects
and then in 3d when we'd layer them
make sure that things that were closer
to the camera actually a lot more volume
and as they fell away from the camera
were actually a lot less that way to the
eye it seemed natural
as if you were standing on the set i got
their files that they had done the 3d
work on and i did the color correction
in 3d looking at it on a 3d projector
being in such a large screen and being
in 3d
is literally going to put you into oz
the 3d experience did heighten it a bit
and now you put imacs on top of that and
it's quite powerful
there's no question that we could not
have created this imax version without
the tremendous efforts of everybody
at warner brothers and their restoration
group a lot of image science has gone
into
dmr technology a render-based process
which is really
a fancy word for saying a lot of
computers are churning away in the
background
so here we are in the imax dmr
production facility where every
hollywood feature
destined for imax presentations is
optimized and honed shot by shot to
bring out all of the detail and reduce
the noise
won't you take me with you why of course
i will
we're always trying to mine information
that's intrinsic to the negative
and contained in the negative dorothy
for the first time i saw that she had
freckles and the
scarecrow's face is burlap and i never
saw that texture on television and in
imax you
feel it we're also taking advantage of
all the unique attributes of
audio that happen in an imax theater
warner brothers did a great job taking
the original
wizard of oz soundtrack and bringing it
into a surround environment
imax takes it one step further we have
an extended dynamic range which means
our loud is louder and our quiet is
quieter we have a frequency response
that goes down to almost 20 hertz while
most others stop at 40. and that's the
stuff you feel that's what makes it
tactile so
when you hear an imax movie
you'll feel in reality i'm not afraid of
her
i'll see you reach the wizard
given the legacy of the film really
retaining the spirit
of everything that went into making this
film 75 years ago was critical to us
from the conversion process to the imax
mastering there has got to have been
easily a thousand people involved
it's magical it's beautiful it's
intimate it's emotional
the audience is they're going to
rediscover a classic
you